[Music]
it's nice to keep it public too because
if if something goes down it makes it
real too you know thank you for fixing
those gold chains I always want a white
man to put my gold chains on me I love
when white men put gold chains on me
yeah I'm sitting here with martalis
Bennett one of the most engaging
talented creative uh athletic Superstars
that I've ever met in my life thanks so
much for being here what's on your
chains baby jesuses two baby Jesus just
his head though can afford the whole
body just go to communion they hand out
the body ofr
yes that is like an A+ no they do hand
it out too and then you get to drink the
blood too and they and they sing a song
back in the old I know it was the blood
but you can't sing in a high pitched
voice I know it was the blood for me see
you say hi it's like it's happy yeah
yeah but this is like wait in water you
can't say
that in the water we can't afford this
why do you have two baby Jesus heads
well cuz I I didn't like one one just
didn't frame my body right it's like
when you decorate the coffee table you
can't put one or two books it has to be
three books and this is your coffee
table Yeah so it's like three or five on
my body two or five works and I was
going to have five Jesus as that would
be crazy yeah I mean I I'm a praying man
but to walk around five jesuses is a
little crazy they call you the orange
dinosaur sometimes dinos the black
unicorn black Einstein black unicorns
are not scary at all black unicorns are
we're just they would be a black unicorn
is that that's what makes it a good uh
name because it's offputting it's
beautiful creatures like think about the
black stallion now put a horn on it does
that creep it out the add an horn take
the horn away I'm on it I like it a lot
put the horn on get away put the horn on
I'll get on
that but that's good because you are a
football man and you want an you want an
uh you know intimidating name why I
picked the black unicorns because not
just because it's intimidating but
mainly because it's magical and I feel
magical everywhere I go it's like I'm
rainbows and cupcakes as I go
walk around
town you're rainbows and
cupcakes yeah like just rainbows
and cupcakes people say your don't
stin you damn right don't smell like
baked
goods what that's amazing what what what
position do you play for the Bears uh
tight end is that a run one yeah I run I
catch the ball sometimes and uh try to
score touchdowns I block make me block
if somebody runs I don't tackle them I
don't tackle you don't go with him I do
if I'm blocking for him and then you
might if the ball came through no I
would help him score I'm on offense I
don't do defense only defense
goes what is the difference so okay so
one person so object okay this is the
object of the game this is football
right this is going to be us cuz this is
cool all
right so this is me this is offense you
are magical yes so okay so basically
this guy job this is the football my job
is this is the touchdown y whoever is on
offense job is to help this guy get past
here yep and all the guys on defense job
is to stop this guy from getting here
but you're on offense yeah so I I score
I get the glory so when I score I dance
and I do cool stuff oh you dance no I
don't but I should so I'll tell you what
to do okay all right always do a
halfback option it's where you throw it
to the halfback and then he throws it
they never see that halfback pass yeah
halfback pass
or do hail Mar that's the one where
everyone just
runs they call it hail Mary cuz it's
like a prayer yeah you got to you got to
PR like this is our last chance of
actually trying to score so it's a hell
married and then you saying I knew it
was the blood after you score yeah so
like I always wonder cuz when guys like
make a great play to win a game they
like I would like to thank God you know
it's like yes God but then when they
lose they be like oh we just didn't lose
like God wasn't there that day I would
say thank God for the loss yeah cuz
that's not only just there and victory
the fall and the Redemption of God's
[Music]
grace